Monday night we saw the Broncos and the
49ers get together in Denver for the
last game of week two of the preseason
it was the first game from Jimmy
Garoppolo since he tore his ACL week
three against the Chiefs last season and
what you need to know this morning is
that Jimmy G did not look good in
limited work one first 6 0 yards no
touchdowns one interception a zero point
zero passer rating he was on the field
Chris for three snit series 10 snaps it
did not go well for Jimmy Garoppolo last
night not as badly as it did last week
when he threw interceptions on five
straight throws at the training camp
practice but still this with everyone
watching primetime Monday night Chris
not good no not good I mean had a ball
drop that was probably gonna be a pick
six interception there that we just
showed on the highlight got a little
unlucky with two tip passes at the line
of scrimmage but regardless hey he was
uncomfortable you could tell that he did
not look like himself in the game and to
be expected this is a guy that has not
played a lot of football and really has
had the last year off and is just
getting back into the flow of things so
am i concerned yet it am I going oh no
what about Jimmy G is this gonna work
no I'm not there yet I'd like to Salette
him play another game get his feet
underneath them but it was still enough
to go Wow
I mean you just don't expect to see that
out of an NFL starting quarterback or
out of a guy who's making twenty seven
point five million dollars the first
interception Mike I mean who was he
throwing dude do you know I'm not sure
if he was thrown on the inside guy the
outside guy but it just tells you tells
me that is his eyes and his brain was
everywhere why he was playing and and
and look at what we just take for
granted that a quarterback who shows
some degree of skill at some point early
in his career is always going to play
well but it's a fragile process it is
and your confidence can get shattered
and whether it's the injury and worrying
about the knee whether it's what
happened in practice last week when he
threw those five interceptions on
consecutive plays you've got to get him
back to a point where he's got that
conference where he's got that vision
where it all kind of hit
in that sweet spot where you can go out
and perform and as of right now now to
get he was only on the field for three
series ten snaps yeah it's still as of
right now work needs to be done to get
him in the right mindset for week one or
it could be a horrible showing from
Garoppolo and the 49ers to start the
season yeah I think that's I mean that's
fair I mean he's he's one of the biggest
question marks in the NFL and certainly
one of the biggest question marks on the
San Francisco 49ers football team they
have a lot of things going in the right
direction you know I think is if you're
looking at is a guy who evaluates
football like you and I do you go okay
offensive lineman offensive line pretty
good defensive line pretty good
especially if they're healthy you know
get in Quanah alexander our linebacker
they've got some new receivers they got
some new running backs everything looks
like it's on the up-and-up in san
francisco along with it being Lynch in
Shanahan's third year but we don't know
what Jimmy Garoppolo is yet to this
point and this is the first time he's
really had a faced adversity in his
career and yes it was a bad week all
together whether it's the interceptions
in practice and this I think it does
show these in a little funk and Mike you
made a great point I mean it's it's
fragile sometimes you can be healthy and
never be injured and go through some
fragile moments mentally as a
quarterback where you just go man our
offense doesn't have the Mojo I'm not
seeing the field good the ball is not
coming out of my hand well let alone if
you're worried about your front leg
which was an ACL tear and all those
things and I think you're right he's
kind of got to build himself back up and
Kyle Shanahan is gonna have to build his
confidence back up to he gets that Jimmy
GQ swagger again and to the extent that
there's any merit to the notion of the
hair of the dog that bit you he gets to
go back to Arrowhead Stadium site of
that torn ACL his next preseason game
great opportunity to exorcise a dead war
it's going to continue to spiral before
we move on though let's hear directly
from Jimmy Garoppolo with his reaction
to his performance in his first game
back since tearing the ACL it's
something that I haven't done in a year
obviously so you know got knocked the
rust off and everything and you know
thankfully we have a short week this
week so we could bounce back quickly but
it's uh you know the first step of
getting back into it you know obviously
a little little frustrated but that's
the NFL you know it's I unfortunately we
all get to play
whole game right now so you know it's a
you only get so many plays you wish you
could be out there for more so you could
bounce back and everything but it's uh
you know it is what is the preseason
right now so just gotta take it in shot
yeah I guess some 49ers fans would say
fortunately he didn't play the whole
game last night but there is some merit
to the idea UVA plenty of guys start a
game rough and then it it it comes later
work the rust off you know you work out
the kinks you have a better performance
as the game unfolds dad that's right and
yeah you know he the one thing I'll say
even though he didn't look real
comfortable playing he's not on the
sidelines like with bad body language or
there he carries himself the right way
which is encouraging to me too and one
other little point I think that's worth
making making about this you know when
you practice against the team all week
right just like the 49ers and Broncos
did joint practices you know you you run
all these plays Denver's defense gets to
see all these plays you know you also
got to be careful sometimes the defense
has seen so much of your plays and
you've seen so much of them that it
comes to the game and maybe Vic Fangio
changed some things that he had done all
week just to throw some curveballs and
you know those are little things that
can trick an offense trick Shanahan chip
trick or oppelo because you go oh they
played this coverage all week when we
did this we'll just continue to do this
and Vic Fangio of course the night
before maybe goes hey I want to change
it we showed this all week and now I'm
gonna blitz out of this formation and
that can lead to some rough times too I
just thought that was worth bringing it
up when again were four days away from
Jimmy Garoppolo next opportunity to
continue his preparation toward week one
of the regular season
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports